[Music]
kept you waiting on Metal Gear Solid's
hallmarks have never been represented
better than in Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground
zeroes it combines tense action and
best-in-class cutscene direction that
stands above any other game in the
series but naturally due to it being a
prologue the narrative ultimately
concludes harsh sooner than you'd like
but on the other hand after the credits
roll and a handful of side missions
unlock the best parts of ground zeroes
are just getting started the story
sequences here captivate with impressive
cinematography and the Metal Gear has
always been recognized for having
high-quality cutscenes they're usually
spotted by inconsistent animation and
over-the-top voice acting thankfully the
opposite is true here characters move
and speak with such natural grace and
even though it's jarring to hear the
recognizable Kiefer Sutherland voice big
boss and place a fan favorite David
Hayter his delivery is far more
realistic and believable at the end of
the day your mission begins in a typical
dramatic fashion on a dark and stormy
night at Camp Omega a military black
site on the coast of Cuba you need to
infiltrate the heavily guarded base to
rescue a member of your entourage and
with only a shred of evidence to point
you in the right direction you'll have
to rely on your powers of observation
eavesdropping in some light
interrogation to succeed as such ground
zeroes is designed for stealth gameplay
and with a minimal HUD a narrow
third-person camera angle and a
sprawling base filled with threats
sneaking behind enemy lines has rarely
felt this tense unlike older games in
the series there's no automated radar to
keep tabs on nearby enemies the only way
of tracking an enemy is to first spot
them with your own eyes and only then
after marking them with your binoculars
can you follow their movements should
someone catch you in the act you have an
opportunity to redeem yourself when the
game enters reflex mode this bullet time
like slow-motion effect gives you a few
seconds to disable your spotter with
short-range attacks or a well-placed
shot to the head in order to avoid
triggering a base-wide alert no matter
how careful you are it's a given that
you'll eventually be spotted immediately
alarms blare and enemies sometimes and
armored vehicles flock to your last
known location in the past I handy icon
in a countdown timer would help you
determine where your enemies are and how
long you have to remain in hiding before
they give up their search now with those
features removed you have to monitor
live radio communications in order to
gather the same Intel nothing is simply
handed to you in ground zeroes is a far
more tense and rewarding experience for
it how well you manage to complete your
objectives determines the rain
you earn at the end of a mission and
everything from the number of times
you're spotted to the amount of
casualties you caused along the way has
an effect on your score and the rewards
you earn such rewards include weapon
drops at the start of missions and in
mission trials that can significantly
alter your trajectory during their peak
playthroughs rankings aside you don't
need to sneak in the shadows if you
don't want to and with an entire
military base worth of toys at your
disposal sometimes it's fun to stand
tall and announce your presence armed
with c4 and RPGs you're fully prepared
to blow up vehicles destroy watchtowers
and charge in guns blazing when the mood
strikes you the dichotomy that exists
between stealth and action-oriented
gameplay lends itself to fear tension
and excitement one moment you can hear a
pin drop and the next you're bolting
across a chaotic military base with
bullets whizzing by your head and
desperation clouding your focus if this
was a more linear experience perhaps the
allure of this contrast might wear thin
but given the options at your disposal
ground zeroes almost never gets old
unfortunately if you hope to be
entertained by an equal helping of metal
gears typically perplexing and
intriguing narrative you're almost
certainly going to be disappointed
there's some fat to savor here but once
you've digested the cutscenes that
bookend the main mission it's a pure
gameplay driven experience from then on
out though it's unusual for everything
to take place in a single location
there's so much to do and see and
whether you take a stealthy or head-on
approach infiltrating camp Omega is a
thrilling experience that shouldn't be
missed
you
[Music]